[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
MARC HAGAN-GUIREY: Thank you.
And thanks very much
for coming, guys.
Obviously, I'm here to talk
to you about my new book.
The full title is "Journey
to The Last Jedi, Star Wars
Kirigami," which I'm
still quite excited about.
And I'm going to take
you through quite
a short presentation.
I would normally do it
over the course of an hour,
but we haven't got
that much time.
So excuse me if I don't
really stop to breathe
or anything for a bit.
And if I'm sort of bungling
it, just kind of nod and smile,
and pretend I'm making sense.
And so before we get started,
obviously, with the workshop
stuff, I'm just
going to take you
through what the
fundamentals of kirigami
are, and also,
how I got into it.
And this is quite
nice, actually.
I did my first Comic
Con a couple of weeks
ago, which was a
big deal for me.
And I managed to pull a
crowd of like 40 people.
So I was really chuffed by that.
But they'd put me in a room
with a capacity of 1,500 people.
And when you get 40
people spread out
amongst that kind
of space, it was
kind of a bit disheartening.
So it's actually really
nice to do something that
is a little bit more intimate.
So thank you, and welcome.
And so kirigami-- you've
probably already done
it before.
It's basically cutting
and folding paper.
And I'm sure all
of you have done
or have made snowflakes
at Christmas.
So you're already
masters at kirigami.
And the difference with
the stuff that I do
is I make kirigami--
like, architectural replicas.
Normally kirigami is
used to make things
like the Eiffel
Tower or Empire State
Building, something like that.
But I find my niche
in making stuff
from movies and more kind of
pop culture related stuff.
So basically, it's a piece
of paper with a horizon.
And then you cut--
and then you're
extruding blocks from it.
So these are the scorelines.
You're not cutting the
whole way through these.
You're just scoring
on this side.
You're scoring on
the opposite side.
And then you fold it
up and extrude a shape.
And then, that's basically it.
But what I do is, I start
to add more detail to it.
And you can add
things like this.
And then you've got a super
accurate representation
of the Google headquarters,
where you just
have that little door there.
But with a little bit
of time and patience,
and starting to build
upon those blocks,
you can start to create models
that are a little bit more
detailed.
And two questions
I'm asked quite often
is, how you got started in this,
and also, do you make mistakes.
And the answer is yes,
I always make mistakes.
And I should pretend that
I'm quite Jedi about it
when it happens.
But I actually have massive
tantrums and clear my desk.
So you are forgiven
if you do that today.
I completely understand.
I started making kirigami
about five years ago.
I'm a digital designer, and
I work on big platform builds
at the moment.
And I was a bit fed up.
I was seven years
into my career,
and I kind of wanted to get back
and do the stuff that I used to
as a kid.
And as a kid, I used to
make stuff all the time.
My currency, as a kid, were egg
carton boxes and toilet roll
tubes.
And basically, every time
my mom would come home
from doing the groceries,
I'd immediately
be decanting cornflakes
into Tupperware boxes
so that I could have
that box and make
a fortress, probably,
for He-Man and Skeletor
and all that kind of thing.
So that's basically what I did.
And even now, as an adult,
when I'm putting a toilet roll
tube into the recycling
bin, I'm going,
oh, I could make a light
saber out of that really well.
Except, well, I don't
do that anymore.
But people do--
I do often think about where
was the kind of turning point
for me.
What was it that really
kicked this all off for me?
And there's some
people that I will
be forever grateful
to that introduced me
to the catalyst of
this adventure for me.
And it's these guys.
This is S Club 7, one of the
greatest pop acts of all time.
And it will make sense in
a minute, bear with me.
So I'm a huge fan of
Frank Lloyd Wright.
And so you know who
Frank Lloyd Wright is--
an American architect
whose major work
is around the 1920s and 1930s.
And basically, when
I was in LA once,
I pretended to be
a multibillionaire
and walked up to a Frank
Lloyd Wright house,
having convinced Christie's real
estate that I was very wealthy
and was about to buy
one of his buildings.
But that talk is for
the extended version.
In case you don't know
Frank Lloyd Wright,
you probably are quite
aware of some of his work.
He designed and
built Falling Water,
probably one of the most
famous residential buildings
of all time.
A little fact is that he'd
been blagging the whole time
to his client that he had
completed the designs for it
over the course of
a couple of years.
And when they said--
they wrote him a letter
to say they were coming
to come and review the plans.
And he got the letter on the
day that they were arriving.
And he basically kicked
everybody out of his studio
and spent 30 minutes
sketching it up.
And then they arrived
and he presented them
in a 15 minute sketch turned
into the most famous building
of all time.
He also designed the
Guggenheim in New York.
And so I went to see this
Frank Lloyd Wright house,
having blagged my way in.
This is the Ennis House.
It's part of his textile
block series of buildings.
Basically, it's
like a big Lego kit.
It was pre-cast concrete blocks
slotted on top of each other.
Absolutely amazing,
there was four of those
in LA and around that area.
And I've been obsessed
with the building
since I first laid eyes on it.
And it was really damaged
by an earthquake in 1993,
and his buildings don't
weather that well.
So he often used granite
that he'd taken from the site
and mix it in with concrete.
And that made it quite
susceptible to weathering
and made it quite weak.
And so the Foundation that
owned the building had basically
run out of money, and
the building itself
was about to slide off
the side of the hill.
And then they decided to
put it on sale in order
to raise the funds and save the
building from being destroyed.
And that's when I
came in and was, like,
hello, I'm very rich.
Can I come and
see this building?
I need to see it now.
And it was really, like-- it
was an amazing moment for me.
A life changing moment, in fact,
in walking around that space--
it was just it was like an
out-of-body experience for me.
It was very spiritual.
But at the same time, I'm
walking around saying, oh,
and how's the plumbing,
and how is the electricity?
I was trying to pretend that
I really was going to buy it.
And so this house itself
has a long history
in Hollywood of being used
for various locations.
Some of you might
recognize it from--
that's really bad on
the screen that big--
might recognize it from "Blade
Runner," Deckard's apartment.
You can see the
original gates there
and some of the interior shots.
Most of it, of the interior,
was actually a set piece,
but some of the exterior shots.
And also it was used in a
1959 Vincent Price film "House
on Haunted Hill."
And if you haven't
seen this, you've
really got to watch this film.
It's brilliant.
It's proper, like,
skeletons on strings.
And I can't think-- a
proper old camp movie.
And other films
it's been used in
are, like, "Beverly Hills
Cop," "The Rocketeer,"
"The Day of the
Locust," and this
is the TV show within the
TV show of "Twin Peaks."
It was the set
within that as well.
And you know, its influence
is still seen today
with film sets and TV sets.
You can still see how it's been
influential to sets, so again,
with "Game of Thrones."
But the music
connoisseurs amongst
you will know that S Club
7 filmed their 2001 smash
hit, "Have You Ever Loved and
Lost Somebody" at the Ennis
House.
And that was the first time
that I saw that building
and was completely
obsessed with it
and found out as much
as I could about it.
So that ended up
being quite a game
changing, life changing moment.
There's me doing my best S
Club 7 impression at the house.
So when I came home from LA,
having seen the building,
I wanted to make a memento to
commemorate the experience.
And I knew that I wasn't
going to make something out
of toilet roll tubes.
And I didn't want to make
something digital as well,
because I'd kind of
had enough of just
working in digital formats.
And I wanted to rediscover
the joy of making stuff again.
And I came across the
art form of kirigami.
And this was the very
first one that I made.
And I thought, well, I know.
I'm going to make some
more buildings that I love.
And oh, by the way, I do
have a Frank Lloyd Wright
book that's out at the
moment, if you want to.
Makes a great Christmas present.
[LAUGHTER]
So I was set aside--
I started making some
other kirigami models.
This is the Addams
Family mansion
from "The Addams Family" movie.
And this is the house
on "Amityville."
I mean, these are
all big things,
big movies from my childhood,
all the normal films
that 12-year-olds are in
to, like the "Amityville"
and "The Exorcist" and so on.
So once I'd started making
these bunch of buildings,
I realized I had a theme,
and I called that Horrorgami.
And that turned into--
that's "Ghostbusters"--
and that turned into
my first exhibition.
I got a deal with a gallery
to make, to do an exhibition.
And that also led
to a book, which
is a really good Christmas
present as well, if you
want to buy, you know,
subliminal Jedi mind stuff
going on here.
So naturally for
me, I've always been
obsessed with "Star
Wars." so I was always
going to start making stuff.
But because the exhibition
had done so well,
and I'd had a really positive
reaction from the media for it,
I began to think, well, maybe
I could do this officially.
Maybe I could really do
something with Lucas film.
I basically did what
it says not to do
on the Lucasfilm
website, which is don't
send any unsolicited material.
But I did it anyway.
And a couple of weeks
down the line, I
got a phone call from the
global head of marketing
who was interested to
do something with me.
And these are some-- so
that's obviously Leia and R2.
And then you've got a close
up of the Millennium Falcon--
try saying that
with a dry mouth.
And then, I found a couple
of years after that,
I've been continually
talking to them.
And then I find myself on
the set of "The Force Awaken"
trying to not get in the way.
And then accidentally bumping
into JJ Abrams, kind of maybe
on purpose.
Like, oh, sorry, but
he was really nice.
And he sort of juts into me.
And he's, like, oh, who are you
here with and what do you do?
And I'm, like,
well, as it happens,
I have my iPad with me.
And I'm going to show you some--
well, he did.
I wasn't that annoying.
But then he says, oh, I'm
a massive paper art fan.
I'm, like, oh, really?
And then he basically
frogmarched to me
across the set of Starkiller
Base, over to Kathleen Kennedy,
to interrupt her to say, you've
got to look at this guy's work!
It's amazing.
And I'm, like, oh!
So it was the only
time I've ever had
a business card in my pocket.
And I took out this
business card that
was all tattered and dog-eared.
And I'm handing
this going, oh, I'm
a professional paper artist,
and here's my business card.
It was really embarrassing.
But anyway, somehow that card
made its way down the ranks,
and I ended up working with
Lucasfilm on this new book.
And these are some
other pictures.
So I did do an exhibition
of Star Wars kirigami,
but I did that without
them, because I wanted
to kind of push ahead with it.
And obviously, I didn't
call it Star Wars kirigami.
It was called Cut
Scene, and kirigami
inspired by that
"Spaceball" movie, you know?
I did it very carefully.
And I think they
appreciated that.
And when they did call
me, I was like, I'm sorry.
I'm not breaking any laws, am I?
And they were,
like, no, no, we do.
We want to work with you.
And that's how the
book come around.
A piece like this-- so this
is the carbon light freezing
chamber.
That took two years
to get that one right.
And then, of course, as I
said, this led to this book.
So you know, for me, this kind
of whole adventure of kirigami
has been a bit more than
just creating these books.
It's about getting people
to start making stuff again.
And mindfulness is a
really kind of-- it's
a word you hear an awful lot.
And it's a bit icky now,
but, actually, I really
do believe that spending
some time to just make stuff
is a really, really
nice feeling.
You know, switch off your
phone, and turn off your TV
and enjoy that process.
So I'm really glad
that you're here,
and I'm able to share
that with you now.
So I'll shut up now we can do
the Star Destroyer kirigami.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
So basically, it's
really straightforward.
The black lines you cut.
The blue lines you score on
the back, and the red lines,
you score on the front.
So I think you've all practiced
just cutting through the paper.
You know how much pressure
you need to use now, yeah?
No?
Can I hear you?
[MUSIC PLAYING]